en 48 heures cette fin de semaine cette
motocyclistes ont perdu la vie au québec
quatre avaient moins de 30 ans est ce
que les jeunes sont plus téméraires à 19
ans alexis fait les passionnés de moto
répond oui j'ai dû rouler plusieurs fois
avec des gens d'après mon âge les deux
fois où j'ai roulé avec eux ils ont eu
des accidents et qu'il soit en voiture
ou même en moto peu importe le véhicule
il ya toujours un peu un stage là de
vouloir impressionner votre personne et
on se met en danger on fait moins
attention à ce qui passe autour
la témérité l'inexpérience et surtout
l'inattention cause la grande majorité
des accidents même jus sur autoroute et
avec son téléphone à côté et on le voit
qu'ils baissent les yeux et il décale un
petit peu sur les voix de droite voie de
gauche
sans forcément regarder ce qui se passe
autour de lui
si tout le monde y met du sien qui
respecte les règles ont transporté des
motos ce triste que du côté des
automobilistes
bon on va pouvoir éviter les accidents
et le nombre d'accidents est tristement
élevé le dernier bilan de la sûreté du
québec fait état de 123 collision
mortelle depuis le début de l'année 31
de ces décès sont des motocyclistes
ce matin il ya de la pluie on a des
imperméables fluo un automobiliste
occuper ce matin le président de
l'association des motocyclistes de laval
est préoccupé et souhaite une meilleure
collaboration sur les routes plus de
courtoisie phare attention nous ôtons et
départ de ma famille des mères de
famille on veut redonner chez nous ce
world
mais la responsabilité revient aussi aux
motocyclistes et ça commence ici dans
les cours de conduite
je sais que durant les cours les
moniteurs font font un effort important
pour tenter de les sensibiliser au
risque de faire de la moto
inévitablement il ya des risques plus
que plus élevés qu'en automobile c'est
sûr mais après qu'ils ont terminée
course exquis entre les deux oreilles
qui se passe et son bon ami on peut pas
y gagnent un automobiliste ou
motocycliste le mot d'ordre reste le
même prudence et vigilance
ici marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal